[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
Season seven a fortnight is here and
with it comes more weekly challenges
this week
dancing in forbidden locations it's kind
of like Footloose I found ten of these
and as we only need seven there's more
than enough so let's go up in the far
left corner by the metal llama is spot
number one bust a move
next get your backside over two lazy
links this one is hidden in the veranda
over the pond you know to do dance
next spot is on the hill south of risky
reals overlooking tomato temple look for
the hill with the Winnebago on top and
dance
down at loot Lake taking the northern
lights but make sure you dance by this
one
below Pleasant Park but above the indoor
football field is this mountain on top
is yet another opportunity to boogie
let's keep out of the snow for the time
being as that's where most players will
be in week one go over to the divot and
climb up pencil Mountain for spot number
six
on the east of the island is the Super
Mario track look for the taco shop for
yet another dance opportunity
from here go south to Paradise Palms
keep East and climb the mountain with
the Dino bones on top two chests and yet
another attempt to ban dancing
now into the snow area in the lowest
point on the west of the map is this
location throw some shapes
and finally from this spot turn into the
island and follow the ski lift nearby to
one more dance location challenge done
and dusted I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade it's been a pleasure and if he's
still here right Kevin Bacon in chat and
I will find you anyway I'll see you next
time
[Music]